so habe ich in der 11 Klasse in Mathe
eine schlechtere Note bekommen nur weil
ich YouTube-Videos gemacht habe ich
hatte zu der Zeit so ungefähr 150.000
Abonnenten auf Youtube weswegen das auch
viele an der Schule wussten dass ich das
mache logischerweise hat sich das dann
auch bei den Lehrern rumgesprochen und
es kam halt schon relativ häufig vor
dass mich Lehrer irgendwie was dazu
gefragt haben sowohl positiv als auch
negativ eine Lehrerin ist mir besonders
negativ in Erinnerung geblieben das war
damals meine Mathelehrerin und sie hat
mich da auf jeden Fall auch verfolgt und
meinte immer so du kannst ja noch nicht
so viel von dir preisgeben du willst ja
später niemals vernünftigen Job bekommen
also wirklich super negative Einstellung
und dann hat sie mich aber trotzdem
gefragt ob ich nicht Lust hätte bei ihr
in der 7 Klasse mal so eine Frage Runde
so eine Stunde zu machen wo ich einfach
so als Experte Fragen beantworte weil
die haben halt irgendwie die Gefahren
von Social Media durchgenommen und zu
der Zeit hatte ich da aber irgendwie
nicht so Lust drauf ich war noch jünger
und habe mir das wahrscheinlich noch
nicht so ganz zugetraut und ich war in
Mathe vor allem in mündlichen echt immer
gut ich stand so zwei plus zwei meistens
und dann kam die nächsten Noten und ich
stand einfach plötzlich drei minus
selbst die Mädels in der letzten Reihe
die nie was gesagt haben waren besser
und ich dachte mir so alter du
trotzdem haben das auch viele Lehrer
supporte das muss man